我是呢和我的老公是去年5月份认识的，然后到现嗯，然后相处的是8个月，然后今年1月份刚结的婚，但是我们没有领结婚证。嗯，然后呢，就是我结婚之前呢，我自己有一些外在，但是相处的过程中呢，我也有和他说过这个事儿。嗯，他当时也说愿意和我一起来承担我的这个债务。嗯，然后结婚以后呢，就是两个人因为性格呀，因为这个钱呀，很多方面就是频繁的吵架呀，冷战，然后就感情不很好。然后就就是因为一点小事吧，我俩就十天半夜的不说话，就是长期的是这样的一个状态。就结婚以后也都是我自己来还，然后到目前为止，他只给我还过两个月。嗯，然后就是说他在那个夫妻生活方面也是不是特别感兴趣吧，基本上我们也没没有。
然后就是最后一次吧，我们因为那个啥吵架，然后就是动手了。嗯，我感觉他也是就是那种下下死手了。然后然后我两点那个啥口的就是有点毁人了那种现在就是准备分开嘛，分开的话，他就是现在要求我就是把那个彩礼彩礼当时给了10万块钱嘛，他现在要求我就会把彩礼全额退还给他。然后那个我想问问问题，就是说我这个彩礼。
我现在因为我不知道我应该退还他多少，因为现在就是大结婚，1月份结的婚嘛，到现在是8个月。
我俩是不领，嗯，你俩也没有没有怀过孕，也没有这个流过产，也没有这些事儿，是吧，没有。
嗯，像你的这个情况，首先没有领结婚证，那这个彩礼的话，原则上就得退。然后，嗯，当然我们也要考量什么这个彩礼钱花到哪里去了。比如说，他给了你10万的彩礼，然后你拿出一部分钱交了房租了，或者买菜生活，对吧，两个人一起旅游啊，买机票啊什么的。如果说你要能拿出这些证据，证明这些彩礼确实用到了你们俩的共同生活当中去，还能抵掉一部分自己个彩礼就是用在那个我我现在就要了10万块钱，然后我就是来还我的债，但是还没还完，就是还了还了一半吧。
那你这事呢，我接下来讲的话，你认真听，认真听，对你有一定的帮助啊，就是钱这个事儿，它是不记名的，对不对？嗯，就钱这个事儿，它是没有办法区分出这笔钱是哪笔钱，那笔钱是哪笔钱的对吧？那你平时你的工资是不是花在两个人生活当中去了？你的工资是不是得对吧？点个外卖呀，吃个饭呀，买个衣服呀，买个化妆品啊，交点物业费呀，交点水电费啊，是不是得交？
嗯，对吧？那我可不可以认为我这个彩礼钱其实就是花到这生活当中了呢？
我话只能点到这儿啊，你要认真琢磨这个逻辑啊。对我明白就是说他那个在在这结婚期间，他也没给我没给过我钱，就是生活费啊，啥都是我自己之前上班在花着自己的钱。哎哟，你这孩子脑子怎么转不过来呢？我的意思说白了就是他给了我10万块钱彩礼，但是我共同跟他生活了8个月，生活这8个月当中，所有的生活费都是我在负担，我为什么不可以拿这个彩礼钱来负担这个生活费呢？
我明白你的意思了，懂啊，嗯，懂了就行啊。然后之后我还有一个问题，姐就是我因为我是单亲家庭嘛，然后现在情况也就是自己身体也不太好，就是嗯，现在跳了20多个吧。然后现在就是我想让你给我点建议，就是我以后的这个这个路应该要怎么走，比如说再再要是再婚的话，是应该怎么去选择这样的，想听听您的建议。
嗯，你学的是什么专业呀？
我就是大专学的一个那个，嗯，其实我就是文化不高，嗯，那你现在你工作大概一个月挣多少钱呀？
嗯，3000~4000这样哦，那你娘家人就是能给你帮衬帮衬吗？你欠这20万当年是怎么欠的呀？
现在20万是我自己之前就是嗯，之前自己创业赔了点，后来一部分就是因为我这个去身体不好嘛，去看病呀什么的，嗯，累了挺多了。
你欠这20万，每年要产生多少利息啊？
现在基本上就是没有停息了，基本上没有利息了。就是嗯，对家里娘家人爸妈是干啥的呀？
嗯，我爸自己开了一个小店，但是现在也就是很一般经营的就是就是收入不了多少钱。然后那个父母离异，我妈就是又自嫁了。这样子的。嗯，没有兄弟姊妹啊，我有个妹妹啊，妹妹多大年纪啊。
你妹妹27，她是那个本科，现在在北京工作。
妹妹也还没结婚是吧？没有，那等于是家里面亲人也没有人能帮衬得上你是吧？对，帮不上。
嗯。
实话实话，姐妹现在你的这个情况啊，嗯，一个月挣个3000块钱，4000块钱这个工作的话，你你真的还还不如说我看我能不能支个摊儿，我能不能卖点吃的。你知道现在路边啊，我我不说我不说别的，我就拿龙飞自己能够亲眼能够看到的他们的赚钱的模式啊，就是会剪头发的。有没有会剪头发的这些老师啊，人家直接在路边就支个镜子啊，一盏灯，然后一个坐凳儿，然后一个收款的二维码，10块钱一个，就不用那个洗头，不用吹头，就直接剪啊，直接剪就10块钱一个。人家一晚上要剪10个就能挣100块钱，那真是纯正哦，他又不用交房租，又不用交水电费，又不用啥啥啥都不用交，对吧，就是在路边支个摊人，一晚上就能挣100块钱，呃不说对，差不多吧，你要减10个话就能挣100块钱，但是如果你白天也减呢，可能这一天下来的话，挣两三百块钱都没有问题。那一个月下来的话，就是一万多块钱，比你那个去打工挣那三四千块钱要强多了。我讲的我只是说讲一个思路，你现在如果说没有一个人能帮你的话，那就得你自己还这20万的债，没错吧？
你自己还这20万的债，你要靠你一个月挣3000块钱，4000块钱你压根儿还不上，因为你还得吃啊喝呀，你得租房子呀，你养活自己都成问题，你就得换个思路。你想着我到底能够学点什么手艺，我在路边，我支个摊儿，我先把我自己的这个债务问题解决掉。因为你身上有债务问题的时候，人家现在相亲的也好，找对象的也好，大家都很现实，大家日子过得都不容易，没有谁说上来就愿意给你还20万的债务的。
是不是因为咱们自己是这个条件，原生家庭也不好，学历也不高，因为挣钱能力又不行，咱们寄希望于自己能找一个那种上来就给我还20万债的人吗？可能吗？那就再问问你长得好看吗？对吧，性格好不好，吸不吸引人？对吧，有没有异性缘？你要告诉我，龙丽姐，我长得可好看了，可招人喜欢了，追我的人可多了，那可能也也行啊，通过对吧，谈恋爱婚姻，那谁可怜你？嗯，心疼你。
帮你一把，但关键是咱自己有没有这个条件。
嗯，我我懂了。嗯，还有就是王菲姐，就是刚刚那个问题，就我的老公如果说是我跟他说了以后，这笔钱我用在哪里哪里了他他要是说不行的话，他非要就是一直要要这个钱，那就只能去那个那个那个地方是吧，是的，没错，也不容易啊，对吧？就是刚刚这个姐妹就属于典型的背后空无一人，没有人能够成为她的依靠，她就只能靠自己。只能靠自己，就现在咱们一样，这个社会上，以我现在的这个年龄和我现在的生活和身体状态，我能干什么？挣钱是比较多的。我跟你说，他要是那个耐心比较好，比较喜欢小孩子，或者干嘛的话，现在你要做家政啊，做月嫂啊，做育儿嫂啊，挣钱老多了。深圳，你去了解一下，基本上一个育儿嫂的基本的工资。
大概是6到八千最基本的了，有没有在深圳的？深圳的月嫂差不多都是1万起步，没错吧？而且我跟你说，做育儿嫂，做家政，做呃这个月嫂，她有什么好处呢？他钱花不出去，净攒，因为她吃喝拉撒全都在雇主家里面，没错吧？又不用交房租，又不用吃饭，花钱又不用什么都不用花钱。
我只是给刚才那个姐妹就是提供一个思路，如果说背后空无一人的话，就得靠自己。趁着现在年轻的时候，有一把子力气，然后把自己的这个经济条件，如果是个坑儿，咱把坑儿先填了，如果是个平平地，咱就夯实一下，对吧，就积累一点自己的这个安全感。要不然的话，你要说光指着靠婚姻，靠男人，靠谁来帮我还这个债？嗯，挺难的，因为现在大家日子都不好过。很多男生现在你看那个现在失业率，我今天早上还看到一个热搜，说是逃离广东还是什么的。有好多人现在以前在广东可能工资六七千，那突然一下子就降到三四千，那根本就没法生存，因为房租也贵，各方面都贵。
你怎么着房租也得1000多吧啊，然后物业费是吧，就是只是给现在处于困顿中的姐妹们提供一个思路吧。刚刚有个朋友说社区可以免费学月嫂是吧？哦对，说起这个事儿，我再提醒一下大家啊，就是上来就让你交学费的，你要小心点好吧，因为有的机构他就是打着招家政招育儿嫂，招月嫂的这个名头，他实际上就是挣你们的培训费。培训完了之后，他又没有给你们推荐工作的这个能力，或者没有那么丰富的客户资源，他挣的就是你们这个培训费。所以，你就打开点小心啊。